552 instituciones escolares en 138
países la educación a la francesa se
sigue expandiendo por el mundo con una
amplia red de establecimientos que
cuenta con profesores nativos y también
locales con el fin de seguir ofreciendo
una educación de alta calidad el
director de la agencia para la enseñanza
francesa en el extranjero inauguró un
instituto regional de formación en
bogotá para que los maestros nacionales
se integren mejor en el sistema
educativo francés
[Aplausos]
decidimos crear 16 institutos regionales
de formación en el mundo estábamos
organizados por zonas de formación pero
quisimos fortalecer nuestra capacidad de
formación en términos cualitativos y
cuantitativos o
cuantitativos porque con el desarrollo
de la red debemos formar cada vez más
profesores en la red hay profesores que
vienen de francia pero no son
suficientes así que debemos formar
profesores que contratamos localmente en
los establecimientos contratan
localmente y que deben estar formados en
la enseñanza francesa
en 2018 el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón estableció el objetivo cap 2030
para duplicar la cantidad de estudiantes
en los liceos franceses en el extranjero
para diciembre de 2021 la cifra de
alumnos aumentó a 380 mil la cantidad de
alumnos desde 2018 ha subido hay casi
40.000 alumnos adicionales en la red así
que la dinámica está ahí
por supuesto se vio frenada por la
pandemia pero se reactivó desde la
entrada a clases en septiembre pasado y
hemos tenido un crecimiento del alumnado
en la red de más de 2%
francia cuenta con la red educativa
internacional más grande del mundo una
expansión que se fortalece invirtiendo
en sus estudiantes y profesores